hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to talk
about the coagulase test so first let's
talk about what coagulase is coagulates
is a bacterial enzyme remember an enzyme
is a biological catalysts eats up
reactions and this particular enzyme
converts the brenigan
to fibrin and this results in blood
clotting so the formation of blood clots
now you might ask well why does a
bacterium need to form blood clots it
seems a bit odd but actually when
certain bacteria have coagulates it's a
virulence factor it makes them more
pathogenic and this is because bacteria
Staphylococcus aureus is a good example
so when bacteria like Staphylococcus
aureus have coagulates this enzyme bound
to their surface they can carry out this
reaction right on their surface and
essentially disguise themselves as a
blood clot this helps them to hide from
the immune system because they don't
look like a bacterial cell they look
like a blood clot which has a role in
normal healthy human physiology so it
helps them to prevent phagocytosis your
sania pestis is another bacterium that
can do this and of course phagocytosis
is that process where an immune system
cell called a phagocyte
actually engulfs and then degrades a
bacterium and I have a video on the
steps of phagocytes cytosis if you're
interested
so the coagulase test is a diagnostic
tool where we use this function of
coagulase to identify and differentiate
between different kinds of bacteria so
for example if you had taken a specimen
from a patient and you had stained it
with a gram
and look at it under the microscope and
determined that it was a gram positive
spherical bacterium then maybe you did a
catalase test to determine that this
gram positive spherical bacterium was
some species of Staphylococcus
well now you can use the coagulase test
to determine if your specimen contains
Staphylococcus aureus or some other kind
of Staphylococcus I which are coagulase
negative and this is because
Staphylococcus aureus produces two types
of coagulates so you carry off the
coagulase test there's two different
forms we'll talk about in a second and
that will help you to determine whether
your specimen is Staphylococcus aureus
or something kind of more benign like
Staphylococcus epidermidis now staph
produces two types of coagulase there is
bound coagulase that stuff is tightly
bound to their surface this is sometimes
referred to as clumping factor and for
clumping factor you use the slide test
and they can also produce some free
coagulase that just kind of gets um
secreted into the medium and for that we
use the two tests so now let's talk
about these two different kinds of tests
typically what's conducted first is the
slide test this is where you have a
slide you have some drops of saline on
the slide and so you add the test
organism to the Saline and then you add
a few drops of plasma typically rabbit
plasma is used all of other kinds can
and then you rock the slide back and
forth not for very long
for about ten seconds and so you're just
rocking that slide sort of gently up and
down if it's a coagulase negative
organism then there would be no clumps
however if it's coagulates positive if
organism produces this enzyme coagulates
then you should see clumps forming in
the saline plasma mixture within that
ten second period so it's very rapid and
pretty inexpensive enough that's a great
thing for a diagnostic test now if you
get a negative result you're supposed to
then carry out the tube test just to be
certain
just to give sort of an added added
evidence for coagulase negative activity
and so it was a tube test you have a
tube again with rabbit plasma and you
inoculate it with the test organism and
then you've incubated at 37 degrees
Celsius which is human body temperature
for about 90 minutes so you can see this
one the slide test you got your results
in ten seconds
this one is more on sort of a follow-up
confirmation takes 90 minutes so I'm
takes longer to do and that's typically
why we do this one first because if it
is coagulates positive you're gonna know
immediately that it's best
Staphylococcus aureus if it's quite
Billy's negative then you've got your
follow-up test now after 90 minutes if
it's coagulates positive then you're
going to get a clot forming vehicle
ulation so you'll actually have this
kind of floating kind of gelatinous sort
of clot that will be at the bottom of a
tube and that would happen if it was
coagulase positive but maybe and there
wasn't as much coagulase and so you
don't get that initial quick reaction
here but you know you it is possible to
to find a coagulase positive organism at
this
now if after 90 minutes there's no plot
you are still supposed to incubate it
overnight just to be absolutely certain
and check again the next day make sure
that there's no Claude so that is how we
carry out the coagulase test if you're
interested in some other diagnostic
tests I mentioned the catalase test
already and I've got a video on that
also the oxidase test is another
important diagnostic tool for
distinguishing between different kinds
of bacteria in a lab or medical setting
you can also check out that video about
phagocytosis if you're interested in
that process and that's it for today
thanks for watching biology professor